[Musique]
savez vous qu'il a déjà été criminel de
diffuser délibérément une fausse
nouvelle au canada que de le faire vous
pouvez vous envoyer directement en
prison l'article 280 du code criminel
canadien si peu qu'une personne qui
publie volontairement de fausses
nouvelles et qui causent un tort peut
faire jusqu'à deux ans de prison
en 1992 dans une décision partagée la
cour suprême du canada déclaré l'article
inconstitutionnelle parce qu'elle
contrevient au principe de liberté
d'expression garantie par la charte
la publicité mensongère de l'or est
interdite et on peut poursuivre au civil
pour atteinte à la réputation
mais si personne est identifié si on
ment en publiant par exemple un groupe
d'immigrants a violé un enfant et qu'on
ne nomme personne
on pourrait plaider qu'il s'agit de
propagande haineuse mais les critères
pour qu'une telle cause soit entendue
sont extrêmement sévères
bref il y a dans la loi un vide qui
permet certaines dérives et pas
seulement au canada aux états unis
l'histoire du pizza gates est un bon
exemple en 2016
edgar m walsh a fait irruption dans une
pizzeria de washington armés jusqu'aux
dents
une fausse nouvelle avait convaincu
l'homme de 28 ans qu'ils devaient aller
libérer des enfants tenus prisonniers
par un réseau de prostitution juvénile
et que ses enfants étaient cachées dans
le sous-sol la pizzeria évidemment tout
était faux mais l'homme y ont cru après
leur probante sur les réseaux sociaux
les forces nouvelles comme le pizza
games peuvent être lucrative pour les
auteurs et les géants technologiques sur
youtube les vidéos qui ont propagé le
pizza gates ont été vue des dizaines
voire des centaines de milliers de fois
le contenu des vidéos étaient
complètement faux mais les publicités
qui étaient intégrés rapporté elle
devrait dollars gougaud facebook ou
twitter affirme faire des efforts pour
contrer ce genre de phénomène il faut
dire que la pression est forte il ya des
pays comme l'allemagne qui prévoit des
amendes pouvant aller jusqu'à 75
millions de dollars canadiens si les
géants comme facebook ou google ne
retire pas les fausses nouvelles de leur
site
ceci dit qui doit avoir le pouvoir de
déterminer ce qui est la vérité le
gouvernement en laissant l'état le soin
de dicter ce qui est vrai ou ce qui est
faux il y a clairement un risque de
censure et aux affects
ici c'est peut-être l'éducation qui
demeure la clé apprendre à reconnaître
les fausses nouvelles car légiférer pour
les éliminer complètement de la sphère
publique est un exercice qui est loin
d'être évident
[Musique]